[Music]
and Warner Brothers new line and MGM
that's like half the studios
here's smile pissed off at the dwarves
taking everything out on the town's
people of Laketown for some reason so
three more passes in this town is done
right something tells me the movie will
find a way to make it last longer or
even stop it
I'm glad the mayor dick isn't getting
away with the goal but you're telling
you the good guy prisoner dude had a
window on only one side but still
somehow I knew exactly when to drop the
makeshift news for the passing boat also
was this Bart's plan when he started
making this room oh he's out the window
and then that fat-ass mayor guy will run
right into it and he'll get pin to the
boat and it'll rip out the wall myself
easy peasy
if this wasn't his plan what's the plan
nearly the entire town is on fire but
thankfully the armory was spared
after clearly devastating the town Smaug
continues his assault on the people who
did him no wrong so that bard has a
chance to find his video game weak spot
meanwhile this giant power which if I
were a dragon I'd have destroyed
immediately just for its pleasure to
burn value continues to go unburned it's
almost like bard is in a video game the
dragon has several powers that could end
this now but decides to give him chance
after chance I don't know man
but seems like you could just kill him
by the time I snap my fingers why isn't
this working
[Music]
burn him already
yeah he killed the dragon the bard and
his son survived this dragon poetically
falls on the town mayor who was trying
to slip off with all the gold also you
teased this whole big thing with smiling
at the end of the last movie only to
have him take a couple fire-breathing
passes at Lake town and then die like a
chum pass not even ten seconds after the
dragon died those are some attentive ass
Ravens how long has gandalf been in this
cage what if he has to pee
has he had any food at all I sure am
glad they spent all this time on this
love story it turned this b-list Wharf
into like only the third dwarf I can
remember in this movie biased we expect
this bull now ex machina where's the
master I was at the random town spoke
number one saw Bard slayed the dragon
but absolutely no one was around to see
the dragon fall on the master of
Laketown you mean to tell me that there
are seven
people in the background here that
didn't notice an up team cone dragon
falling on the master I'm pretty sure
this is a Simpsons episode this dwarf
notices something he can't possibly
notice hundreds of feet below and at an
angle that is not conducive to noticing
things just so they can run down and see
how crazy Thorne has become they said
he's been down here for days but is
conveniently rambling this exposition
just as the other dwarf show up Bilbo
pulls out the Arkenstone to assure the
audience that he has it but this is not
a wise move in general and I'm racking
my brain trying to figure out what good
it does for his character to whip that
out like that
he must meditate dragon the women can
clean now that's racist and why are you
still alive and not in prison also did
we discount Grima Wormtongue this
asshole last movie because I don't even
care if we did he's getting another one
what gold is in that mountain is cursed
we will take only what was promised to
us because that gold is not cursed
Winnie I saw a Darlene Johnny he done
Winnie Nolan Tolliver Tavia Danine Len
and Talia I decided to keep that from
both of you until it was dramatic enough
to reveal his future sour on keeping
these super powerful Wizards alive for
some reason Wow good thing Calandra
decided to show up just when this orc
decided he'd had enough of candle being
lazy in his cage when you see Galadriel
do this he realized what a selfish elf
she's been throughout both trilogies she
had all this power to help people out
and here's the only time she uses her
power ever you know why because Gandalf
needed her that's why
[Music]
Kian boom Sauron introduces himself via
the Lord of the Rings masturbation poem
I am because Elrond and Saruman were
sitting around twiddling their thumbs
while I saved candle hello did Saruman
apparently have the ability to strike
ghosts with their physical weapons and
since these ghosts of the ring wraiths
in Lord of the Rings I don't quite
understand where they go after they get
hit did he become extra ghosts or
something we have just enough power to
be scary
studying ghost soldiers six Aikman
literal eye of Sauron shows up here
making much of the previous trilogies
first movie seemed kind of stupid but
whatever
Bilbo calandria shows two super-powered
wizards what real power looks like
completely undermining their power in
the lotr trilogy and making me wonder
why she did nothing to help in that
entire three movie war against Sauron I
mean she totally banished that asshole
right here in the original trilogy she
was like here's some elf trinkets fare
thee well
who glad that little problem with Sauron
is over without the Ring of Power Sauron
can never again so you knew about the
Ring of Power and knew his name was sour
on here but Gandalf still needs to stop
years later upon reaching for the ring
to go and research what the ring isn't
do Peter Jackson you didn't even want
your own goddamn movies a string is
fading take her to lothlórien where
she'll stay for 60 years earning a
reputation as an elf witch of terrible
power who decides not to ask any
questions about Sauron ever again he
must be hunted down and destroyed once
and for all without the Ring of Power
Sauron can never again hold dominion
over middle-earth okay good enough for
me I won't follow up with any enquiries
until it's too late I need a horse I
need just one goddamn shot in this movie
that doesn't look like a painting got
just daun by the Sun how did ten years
pass but WIDA got worse at visual
effects I came to reclaim something of
mine
there gems in the mountain that I too
desire comment how did elf gems get into
the Lonely Mountain wasn't this just a
mining colony someone either stole these
things and brought him here and the
elves never fought to get them back or
someone brought them here and said you
know what you have more gold than we'll
ever be necessary in life how about some
gems and poured them out onto a sea of
treasure my people also have a claim
upon the riches in that mountain well
that's you the elves and the doors only
two more armies to go before we have a
movie that matches its title be gone
okay maybe this is argumentative but
isn't this a clear case where the non
thorn dwarves could talk some sense into
this guy and remove him from power if he
continues to have a treasure boner that
caused his thoughts be gone the he's
barely 30 seconds right from the gate
but these assholes have all come up to
the balcony already goddamn this movie
Jesus absolutely nothing matters you
know what Peter Jackson doesn't do
enough of weapons handing off and
gearing up for war montages they August
I'm mistaken why is thorne so certain
one of his fellow dwarves have taken the
Arkenstone and his paranoia hasn't
focused on Bilbo the guy who was in the
treasure room longer than anyone yeah
yeah he's under estimating it but seems
like a guy who was out of his mind would
accuse everybody of stealing especially
a burglar also if one of his fellow
Dwarfs did take it then what don't they
have all the power
why wouldn't they use it right now this
is the gateway to reclaiming the lands
of Angmar in the north
it sounds important too bad I don't know
what it means earlier Legolas was
talking about how important this
gundabad place was when it came to
Angmar now the Lonely Mountain is the
most important place again I've heard so
many names are so many places at this
point just get to the fighting already
hey that's the exact same time the elves
are gonna attack we attack at dawn
that's amazing accidental coordination
don't you mean middle-earth Eaters also
he's referring to the we're worms which
honestly I'd rather see how they
negotiated to ally with these things
rather than them being a surprise later
what do you promise aware worm when you
go to battle plenty of earth to eat when
Sauron rises again hey you like that
Bilbo you didn't hear that this is the
halfling who stole the keys to my
dungeons from under the nose of my
guards you know what if this series has
one saving grace it's probably Martin
Freeman I'll take a sin off for this guy
mainly because every time he's on screen
these movies are elevated
dragon-sickness seeps into the hearts of
all who come near this movie well really
only two guys but all of them sounds
better also let's not forget the very
reason why this whole thing happened
Gandalf met with Thorin and told him to
retake the mountain and his vague
reasoning was that Dierker Minds would
turn their heads toward forgetting the
fact that everyone was so scared of this
damn dragon that no one dared go near it
and the idea of sounds returned was not
even considered possible at the time I
don't know what darker Minds Gandalf was
thinking about but none of those
assholes could have killed the dragon
they took a well-placed arrow in a
rumored weak spot to take that fucker
down but Gandalf was worried enough that
he started all this never once did he
seem concerned about Thorin getting
dragon-sickness but oh well gold is evil
I think we all learned something here
today whole Li si Jia
dwarf reinforcements show up at dawn to
making the lonely mountain the same
distance from everywhere an army might
come from basically the Battle of the
five armies is a recreation on a much
larger scale of the anchorman fight in
anchorman oh come ma character says what
everyone in the audience is thinking out
loud
also it's too bad that in their armor
the dwarves and the orcs look exactly
the same because this is going to be a
confusing enough battle as it is elves
decide to help but do so in a way that
renders the elaborate and elegant war a
part wall obsolete so the elves decide
at the last minute to not be total dicks
and save the day I honestly didn't
expect that if only because it's a well
Peter Jackson has gone back to so many
times he has his mail forwarded they're
spinning swords when we were little my
brother and I used to set up army men on
opposite ends of the room and then take
turns shooting marbles at the other guys
army I feel like that's exactly what
Peter Jackson is doing here only with
CGI and with a great deal more wasted
money involved good fathers are always
asking this question is this a Roland
Emmerich movie thanks random woman your
amazing knowledge is only surpassed by
your amazing hearing in the middle of
all this commotion
thanks random man if the random woman
hadn't told bard where she last saw his
family this news would be completely
immaterial somehow beyond all reasonable
doubt bard either hears these kids or
sees them but considering how he plans
to save them in a second look how
fucking far away is can he really see or
hear his family or even have the
wherewithal in the middle of a battle to
look in this direction run away oh my
god - oh it's an obscene amount of time
to kill these kids get down how about
get out of the way do you know for a
fact that this carts going to leapfrog
your kids they are dead movie that loves
killing hates any death that is logical
take them to the Great Hall and barbecue
today I can't tell you how many times
this movie has made me side with
frustration wait no yes I can
172 and Counting see that you'll return
it Oh get me to safety saw you can't
paint Bard as this savvy Superman here
oh and then have him miss or ignore evil
dudes obvious evilness to the point of
entrusting him with the lives of his
children well I'm starting to think a
toddler wrote this script or a youtube
comment roll again
the elf flies in at the last second to
not be a total asshole did you make a
scrip to draw on three thousand machine
with various storytelling elements as
buttons and your small child played
around with the one day and you were
like damn this is pretty good cuz he hit
that button twice and you somehow missed
it are we winning I forget it I don't
care
without this hearing the voices in the
dialogue we just can saw on the last
scene seen the audience would be totally
clueless as to thorne state of mind
apparently all it takes to get rid of
dragon-sickness is to think really hard
about what an asshole you've become and
a fantasy sequence involving
metaphorical gold running
a Zonk has been doing nothing but
narrate every time we see his dumb ass
every time I see him I get weary not
because he's the bad guy I want to see
get killed but because nothing he does
or says is interesting enough to make
him a worthwhile villain
Thorin luckily comes to his senses at
Magic Hour that's pretty cool I guess
but where did they hang this Bell from
to smash down the barricade I actually
would have preferred to see them rig
this up and make it work rather than
this dramatic entry into battle Oh No 13
more dwarves the dwarves they turned her
baseball caps inside out also that's all
the dwarves needed was their king
the massive outnumbering by the orcs had
nothing to do with their asses getting
kicked before and considering what we've
been told about dwarves and their thirst
for battle what a bunch of bull this
emotional spark is this whole battle is
so confusing I don't even know why there
are people still left to fight the orcs
last we saw the elves were getting their
asses kicked and haeseong called us the
dwarves were pretty much spent yet none
of these armies look like they have any
less numbers than before how did this
turn from a landslide or victory with
massive death on all opposing signs -
well if we just believe in ourselves we
can beat these guys Alfred doesn't Eric
Idle playing a woman impression makes me
realize I could have been watching Monty
Python instead man the universe just
keeps gift wrapping opportunities for
this guy to be a dick if there's time to
bro-hug during the battle it's really
more of a skirmish of the five armies
isn't it there's too many of these
buggers Thorin I hope you get up one
well no I just figured your emotional
strength will carry the day we're going
to take on today's magic ram appears out
of nowhere the moment Thorin says this
suddenly everyone has Rams their fellow
dwarves didn't bring them and neither
did the elves so who had them
starring
or drama and despite the fact that no
one can tell who is who even when
they're up close old-ass Gandalf can
figure out who these dwarves are from a
distance while they ride magically
appearing ramps why would you dismount
the superfast giant goat of destruction
oh no one and the others might only just
now be in danger goblin mercenaries know
more about a hundred we'll take care of
them go because a hundred goblin
mercenaries are no match for two fucking
dwarves meanwhile in this cutaway you'll
forget Thorin is horribly outnumbered
and should probably be dead around or
thirteen or fourteen or so but the magic
of editing will make it so that he wins
the battle the movie is cutting away
from it all away
Bart's family shows up like a thought
bubble to prove a point is that all I
don't know I was too busy forgetting you
just took out a hundred goblins by your
damn selves also another thing I forgot
about were those damn we're worms
those were supposedly going to be a big
deal but they vanished from the movie as
soon as they arrived guess they don't
give it anymore
plenty of middle-earth to eat regardless
of who's in charge every fucking
helpless person in this movie gets saved
at the last second by someone who was
previously nowhere near the place it's
not amusing anymore
have you come to expect this kind of
thing every time why is it even film
like it's supposed to be a surprise how
can it be that every orc is worthless
except azog bilbo decides my sword and
ring
I'll let rocks decide this thankfully on
the Nolan Ryan of hobbits goblin hasn't
missed once this may actually be the
least believable thing about this movie
I think I'm a battle crazy orc with some
sort of multiple blade killing
instrument in my hands but for Bilbo
because he's so special to this story I
will not use my weapon in a manner for
which it was created
luckily this bats last action on earth
is to fly just long enough to get you to
safety here motherfucking happens again
love story that wasted all our time
finally ends in the third movie with 40
minutes left skip
[Music]
Legolas knew if he stabbed this troll
and brain the trolls brain powers were
transferred to his sort then he'd be
able to make the troll hit but a tower
to form a bridge that is the exact
length he needs to cross it this movie
about elves and dwarves is strangely
titled the hub fight scene has no
tension due to previous trilogies
existence and once again this troll will
wait an obscene amount of time to kill
the helpless person in front of him this
has an unforgivable level of ex machina
that even Harry Potter is dubious of it
yeah everyone I'll tell you this movie
has violated me so completely
I'm beginning to mistake this for love
we saw was so fake that it can't even
register as cool or an adrenaline rush I
don't think I could be more offended
even if Peter Jackson rode into the
theater on a horse and started beating
us with that carrot he always eats in
these movies I guess somewhere there's a
battle still raging with the dwarves in
the other hundred thousand orcs that
were around here but none of that
matters anymore
here come the Eagles still clearly
worried about those men and their great
bows of you which would have shot them
down if they brought Gandalf and crew
closer to the Lonely Mountain can't we
just admit they only show up when the
story calls warrant and let go of all
those stupid reasons why they didn't fly
them further in the first movie let the
hate flow through you they Oran jumps
off the eagle and turns himself into a
bear which allows him to survive this
jump here's one of the trilogy smartest
moments and we'd maybe even consider
taking a sin off for it later a song is
going to be trapped under the ice and
drowning and still come back for another
attack so they waste the smart moment in
order to do something dumb later and I
think that's worth two goddamn sins god
damn it I bet you thought after we gave
the last thing to sins because of this
that we wouldn't sin this but your own
alive azog is a sinful Azoff man I knew
the Eagles are dicks but not one of them
could help Thorin out here yeah Bilbo
was right the Eagles are here why aren't
they using their healing tears to bring
thorn back to life oh you say that's
ridiculous
welcome to how I felt every time someone
got saved in the last minute of this
movie Kono's find the tuna doc there's a
young Ranger amongst them you should
meet nope look I'm already giving lots
of leeway here that Aragorn is at least
60 in the Lord of the Rings kickin all
that ass but this book right here is an
absolutely ludicrous way to connect the
two movie trilogies hey go find this kid
be his pal he's gonna be great one day I
know this because I could saw The Lord
of the Rings trilogy no wait
also why bother to tell your elf son to
go find a human boy out of all the
places and people to suggest he should
spend time you don't even have to read
the books to find this offensive in
every way besides in fellowship it's not
until they get to the Council of Elrond
that they even meet not one
scene in that movie suggests they had a
long history together me right the beer
damn I should have also told him about
Frodo well I'm sure he'll meet him
someday
look I haven't been able to find
anything confirming that this is Brian
Cranston
but wouldn't it be just like a movie to
put him here for 5 seconds and then
pretend he doesn't exist
you know what the Hobbit could have used
some damn Brian Cranston that's what you
tell the others I said goodbye you can
tell them yourself because in this movie
everything is on demand need someone to
save you click a button the eagle soar
in need to make a point click a button
your family is there the board is this a
good time to ask whatever happened to
Dean thorns cousin he just kind of
disappeared from the movie he's the new
king right now well you don't really
suppose do you that all your adventures
and escapes were managed by the locked
well 95% of them were for sure magic
rings should not be used like I'm
definitely not going to investigate this
ring that you have for another 60 years
and only after I've almost touched it to
see the Eye of Sauron the fact that
sorrow needs a ring to rule the world
and just happened to appear right after
our adventure in Gollum's cave does not
make me suspicious in the slightest
good dead standoff is worried now but
will completely forget about this by the
time fellowship comes along sin the 13
minute credits sin the 13 minute credits
do you have a boyfriend
[Music]
winter is upon us
[Applause]
[Music]
and you have my bow
as my ox and I don't like to think what
Thorin will do when he finds out go jump
down I'm not afraid of Thorin yeah you
will be
[Music]
obviously if Gandalf had used
Squarespace to build a website about his
findings and adventures a lot of things
would have gone a lot smoother like
Gandalf the pedia or something but being
middle-earth there is no internet so
naturally Gandalf somehow forgets
everything he learns in this movie about
Sauron in the ring before fellowship can
happen it's a shame to Squarespace would
have built him a kick-ass website like
they did for us and Jeff Bridges I'm the
dude if you're in the market for a web
site personal or commercial get like all
these little clips that we find and that
people send each other and stuff like
that
and you put it like on one web page our
pals at Squarespace are offering
cinemasins viewers 10% off 10% all you
have to do is go to Squarespace calm
slash cinemasins and get started pretty
darn easy no fuss no muss you might
think we only care about the videos and
not the business side of things we
actually care a lot about the business
side of our strange little beast here
and as someone who's gone through the
process of having Squarespace building
your website I can't say enough good
things we got exactly what we wanted our
fans are happy we're happy and I just
really think a lot of you would have the
same happy experience because so head
over to Squarespace comm / cinemasins
today and tell them what kind of website
dreams they can make reality for you
you